midtown high seniors
no wandering
proceed direct knock it off
remember it is a privilege to be here
we are guests of columbia university
science department so behave accordingly
let's not have a repeat of our trip to
the planetarium
come on people let's stay together
proceed up the steps and into the
buildings
uh no charles can we drive around the
corner please
why
the entrance is right there dad these
are public school kids i'm not showing
up for the field trip and the rolls what
you want me to trade in my car for a
jetta just because you flunked out of
every private school i ever sent you it
wasn't for me of course it was
don't ever be ashamed of who you are i'm
not ashamed of who i am
just with him
forget it
hi harry
harry
won't you be needing this thanks tim uh
peter may introduce my father norman
osborne i've heard so much about you
great honor to meet you sir harry tells
me you're quite the science whiz you
know i'm something of a scientist myself
i read all your research on
nanotechnology really brilliant and you
understood it yes i i wrote a paper on
it
impressive
your parents must be very proud i live
with my aunt uncle they are proud hey
you too
let's move
nice to meet you
hope to see you again
he doesn't seem so bad yeah not if
you're a genius
i think he wants to adopt you
you